do we got a vaccine yet or no [ __ ] my
do we got it or no no dog have another
year and a half bro that's the thing
I'll buy does it take so long for
vaccines can you explain that dragon I
mean that to ensure this episode
eventually but why does it take so long
you gotta test it to make sure it don't
kill [ __ ] what okay okay but
how long does it take to kill you like
boom you test it theoretically it could
take a couple months you get it and then
you think you're fine and then some
other [ __ ] happens and all of a sudden
if if that's not how it works
hi in 30 people just tested disinfectant
and we know that don't work what does it
not work for I mean it kills you it does
it kills the vet probably kills the
virus also that's all he said let me ask
you question what is he wrong he's
asking if it will kill the virus if
you're dead can the virus live in you
and I can true that's how you kill the
virus at what cost are you willing to
stop Korona nobody out here in
applesauce what you want him [ __ ]
cured to Corona
Joe Biden more likely to eat a bat but
in all seriousness yeah the way you do
stop the virus yeah the real vaccine is
if you have detergent is death is death
yeah yeah me everybody who died no
longer got it and they can't spread it
they can't spread it that's how you stop
the spread you'll stop doing the work at
a mainstream media too much New York
Times and [ __ ] too smart bro I'm tired
of this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] come in every day
with all information all the answers
would you tell me today all the antibody
tests like only three or 14 of them
actually were
what there's a I don't know okay I
thought antibodies were the guys
throwing the milkshakes of people in
Portland that is probably how they built
the skinny-ass regions antibodies
antibodies not a bra antibodies Asian
[ __ ] came out was like what does it
kill it though does it kill it though
what if he just wants to not be
President he's like let me just get rid
of these [ __ ] keep voting for
me yo just get him out of here you know
that's hilarious wait you're saying what
if he's saying all this [ __ ] so he
doesn't win yes his fan base yeah I mean
just hey guys you listen to everything I
say you want to be corona Lysol in your
veins yo just get this [ __ ] it cures it
everybody starts doing it everybody
starts dying that's gonna vote for him
and oh hey Larry this whole time Trump
has been trying to not be president I'm
down he doesn't want to be pred the
whole time like he's like yeah I grab
the [ __ ] they won't not gonna do nothin
even though we got a global pandemic
right the global pandemic comes over and
is like [ __ ] it I don't know and he's
like the only way I can not be president
of all them die I gotta kill him I got a
killer but at Michigan Oh put him on the
state that I win he's only opening up
the states where people vote for him
he's not open up New York he's not open
up California yeah holy water be
president honey jump you know he never
wanted he just wants to be famous he
just want a new show his [ __ ] got
canceled yeah and now it's like what
does it went up what's the episode of
Seinfeld where the Larry David character
what's his name yeah George George
Costanza does the opposite and
everything works hey we're living in
that episode of the [ __ ] upside
though yeah he the president is the
opposite oh my god guys
[Applause]